all right hello everybody
i hope everybody is doing well tonight
um
i have to admit i am pretty livid right
now
i just found out that we are being put
back into lockdown uh
and it's effective in two days we are
being told that
this is we're now in a red zone
and uh so they're putting everybody back
on lockdown no
no public places open no private
meetings not allowed to invite anybody
to your house
not allowed to go to anybody's house
and so ah man i'm just really really
really annoyed
and so we are a population of eight
million people in quebec
and right now there today two people
died
of coronavirus it's usually people that
are
over in their 80s every day there's like
less than five to three people
are dying uh and so i don't i
and so they're they're shutting down
everything again and i don't totally
understand
they say their purpose is to get rid of
the virus so
i don't understand i'm really really
confused anyway so i'm not gonna
dwell on this for too much let's just
say that
my answers might be a little spicier
than usual tonight because
man i'm just i'm just tired of this
stuff and so
all right and so i didn't want i don't
want to get political with you guys but
uh just very very annoyed all right
and so as you know uh people
who are subscribed on patreon or on my
website
or on subscribe star people who are who
are
above the is it 10 10
limit they're allowed to ask questions
in advance for the q a
so i'm going to go through the questions
and if there's time left at the end
then i will also kind of go through
the super chats if there are some
usually i get through everything
but now every month there's more and
more questions so
so it's getting harder to kind of get
through everything
and so i want to announce so this month
i just want to tell you guys this month
i'm still going to put out the uh the
the patron only video
in the next few days and i'm probably
going
to go into uh
well not probably it's pretty sure by
now i'm going to start to do
maybe one or maybe two videos on uh
sergey win sir gawain and the green
knight i know a lot of people have been
asking me
to go into that story and so i'm pretty
excited to
to do that hopefully
that's going to be some fun there's a
lot of interesting stuff to talk about
there's too much to talk about in that
story and so it's going to be hard to be
succinct you know and i'm going to i'm
going to keep like i'm probably going to
keep the more advanced
and more kind of heavy interpretations
for patron only videos because i did
i recently did like a pretty uh
intensive interpretation of a uh
of a fairy tale of uh yvonne and the
gray wolf on the channel and it didn't
get that many views because i don't
think it's for everybody
all right but you guys who watch the q a
usually you like you like more kind of
intensive stuff
that's my impression at least
all right so here we go so i'm going to
start on
uh my website on symbolic world and the
first question is from josh the mover
so the phenomenon of people chanting i
can't breathe coinciding with the
wearing of mask is particularly
alarming breath is the most fundamental
and seminal aspect of physical life
it seems if we are at a societal loss
for breath that perhaps we are just
about to hit some kind of dead end
where is there left to go things have
been relatively predictable for the last
few years but it seems like that
predictability has come to an
end is there something beyond breath
obviously we christians believe in
spiritual realities beyond physical
breath
but how does this translate into a
symbolic societal level hope or doom
so the id it's not that complicated the
idea is
that this idea of i can't breathe
whether it's from
one side in terms of the mask whether
it's from the other in terms of the
the perception of of oppression from the
system
the other one being oppression and well
but as well
one related to racism the other related
to uh the coronavirus
it has to do with a flood it has to do
with drowning
and so it has to do with this descent
into the waters as
society breaks down one of the
impressions
is that that we can't breathe and so we
kind of
society breaks down um and so you know
there's a relationship
also with the anonymization the
anonymity which comes with wearing the
face masks
i've talked about that before how it is
a breakdown of identity as well
a breakdown of communion and a breakdown
of identity all these things
are kind of happening at the same time
and the image of i can't breathe means
i don't have access to heaven i don't
have access to spirit i don't have
access to
to that which is above and so we kind of
fall down and we start to fragment
below
um so hi jonathan can you go into the
symbolism of the muse is this an example
of the feminine
framing the question uh
i don't know if i would say it's the
idea of framing the question
it has to do with it has to do
with an inspiration
in the sense of how can i say this
because the thing about about the muse
is that what she does is
she connects the divine the the patterns
with
reality and so that is something it's
kind of like a
birthing or a and so it's not just about
the pure patterns because
the muse won't give you the pure
patterns right the muse what the muse
will do is give you inspiration to write
something
or to make music or to create something
because
it's that it's kind of like you are
uniting yourself with the muse
and it's creating this it's creating a
new body
a new creation right it it's kind of a
union
with a you know this vision of the
feminine which will then create a new
work of art so it mostly has to do with
that it has mostly has to do with the
idea of
uniting yourself with something to
create a productive
new life or productive new body
um and so c s
stritzel uh
asked two questions but i'm only gonna
answer one question per person just
because it's too many
so c.s strichl asks i believe both you
and your brother have referenced
abram later abraham being in a place
where everything is corrupt egypt
if i recall correctly you both discuss
abraham's inverted or bad actions
these inverted hierarchies as being
justified or accepted
because if he acted otherwise it would
actually cause him to be highlighted or
targeted
this story reminds me of viktor frankl's
book man's
search for meaning where he states that
no one who survived the concentration
camps was good or noble because one
became corrupted
just to survive there all the good and
noble people
were the first to die can you ex can you
expand on this theme how it relates to
our current social political situation
and how we as individuals should conduct
ourselves in an inverted time and place
i feel that i may be taking away the
wrong meaning from these stories
and i would appreciate any clarification
you can offer
and so it mostly has to do with the idea
of not acting straight and so
it doesn't necessarily have to be
morally corrupt
because obviously it's dangerous to act
in in
let's say in corrupt ways or in kind of
ways that are against your own values or
whatever but there are ways
to not you when you
are the foreigner like when you are the
foreigner when you are not
in your homeland it is very difficult to
to act straight because you don't have
access to
the center you don't have access to the
identity and so you kind of
have to ah you have to act let's say
in a circular manner or kind of on the
on the outskirts and so
and so in terms of how to apply it to
our life today
it most of it would have to would be
something like you have to be cautious
you also have to you you have to not
necessarily trust
when you're in a new place that you
don't know anybody you have to
you're going to do it normally you're
going to be cautious you're going to be
attentive you're not
necessarily going to to engage in the
same way you would if you were among
friends or if you were in your house or
if you were in your church or something
like that
so that there's there's something about
that in there
but there's also something about
the idea that you know i talk about this
where
when the world is let's say let's say
right now
so when the world is upside down even
acting straight looks crooked to the
world and so
you know if everybody is corrupt around
you if you try to be
if you try to be straight it's going to
look crooked for people that are there
and you see it right now in terms of you
know
the idea let's say the idea that in in
our world right now the idea of getting
married and having children
can be seen by some people as being evil
as being a
horrible thing that you're doing for the
environment a horrible thing you're
doing for overpopulation
and so in that sense to act normally to
act in a straight and normal manner
which is uniting yourself with someone
uh
man and woman and having a family you
know
a large family is is you acting crooked
in a world that's crooked but you're not
you're you end up
acting straight and so i think that's
probably in turn
in in terms of our in terms of how to
act or how to behave i think that's
probably the best thing
to get out of that because
but it is important to understand in
stories why
it happens that way because like for
example when we talk about sir
gawain and the green knight i'm going to
show you how this is exactly what
happens to gawain
when he is out in the land of the
of the uh the green knight you know he
is he
ends up acting upside down you know
where he
is he is a prey right usually he's the
knight he's the one combating he's the
one
wooing he's the one attacking but now in
this world
in this when he's in the house of the of
the foreign
person then he is being wooed and he has
to be careful
you know and he is the prey and so
anyways we'll talk about that more in
the video but
it's a good example of seeing if you you
need it's good to understand that
pattern because it
it's not always moral but it is
something about how when you're
outside when you're when you're when you
are the foreigner
then you will see this this pattern kind
of manifesting itself
um and so
isidore asks
an individual tree is a stable symbol of
order but a forest
is a chaos where hansel and greta lose
their way and encounter
a witch there snow white flees and find
the outcasts of dwarves the traditional
force is ancient and untamed where the
demons lurk
and outlaws hide rather than being a
microcosm of a forest they are in a ways
opposites
how does this fit into a traditional
worldview
and so the thing is symbolism is multi
is multivalent it it's polyvalent you
could say there
things don't only have one meaning
things can be seen through different
angles and so
the idea like you said of a
so let's say you have a garden and so
the garden
is a place where the tree acts in the
man because it is
tamed and so in a garden the tree like
in the garden of eden the tree acts as
this connection of heaven and earth
whereas in the wild or in this there's
also
the concept of the wild of the untamed
then like you said then the trees are
in a wild space they're in an untamed
space and so they
take on a different they take on a
different uh
symbolism but nonetheless this some some
trees
sometimes trees in some kind of sacred
forest that have existed in the past
where often where the the brush at the
bottom
is kind of gone and the trees are really
really big
and so there's they create like these
you know these domes
and you're you're kind of in this spares
forest you can also
have this sense that that they have
sacred forests and that these
sacred places also have a kind of
special spiritual meaning
in several uh several cultures so it
just really depends but
what's important is mostly to understand
symbolism within the frame that it's
being posed and so in a story
like for example hanson gretel or in
snow white
uh or little red robin the little red
riding hood
then you can understand because of the
way the forest is used in the story
which aspect of the forest is being
manifested
what is it is it the tree tree aspect of
it or is it rather
kind of haphazard wild aspect of it and
in that case
it is indeed the haphazard wildness of
it
and this is true for almost all
symbolism uh you know
that certain things depending it's like
an algebra it's like a
algebra it's like a formula and then
depending on where
things are in the in the formula they
can take on different
meanings and so you know a good example
is for example let's say just a simple
idea of feminine and masculine
you know i am masculine
let's say in terms of my wife
but i am let's say feminine i have a
feminine place
in relationship to authority let's say
or in relationship to christ
but those aren't confused it's not this
there's no
contradiction because there are
different levels of reality and they're
just different places
and so it's important to kind of be able
to see things in their proper place
and in relation to all the other
symbolic terms to be able to really
understand
what the symbolism is that's why i hate
symbolism dictionaries i really don't i
don't own one symbolism dictionary
because i find them those to be
extremely superficial because they try
to just say this symbolizes that and it
never works that way
um so benjamin
rva asks it seems that a majority of
modern christians lack the grammar to
defend themselves from multiculturalism
without stepping outside their faith
into political ideology
is this a bug or feature of true
christianity i have a hard time
embracing a faith that currently appears
incapable of mustering more arguments
against what our ancestors would have
understood to be invasions and i'm
concerned
that christian universalism is
functioning as a social solvent
in a world with global mobility this is
a stumbling block for me and i would
appreciate your insights thank you for
your work
um
and so i don't let's say in a in a
traditional
world that's in a traditional christian
world
you are allowed to have your group like
you were allowed to have
your nation there was there was not this
idea that
that we need to have some kind of global
one world culture or whatever like none
of that was a traditional christian
trait
you know in in you know the byzantine
empire you
had uh you had different groups you had
the greeks you had the armenians you had
the latins you had the you had at least
at the beginning you you had the cops
you have
all these different groups and
you know and there was probably
crossover between them
but there was also a certain sense of
identity that wasn't attacked let's say
and so there it's normal that there will
always be
some there there's always mixture at the
edge of all identities there's always
places for
for for contact and and exchange and
mixture and all of that
but the problem that we have now that
we're seeing
is rather there's an act of hostility
right and so it's not just
it's not just that we notice that yes if
there are greeks and armenians living in
a
into in a in a place and there's there's
going to end up always being some
mixture between them
you know but there is there isn't now
what we have is this idea that
if you are attached to being a greek or
an armenian
you know that's evil like you're not
allowed to be attached to
your group whatever that is you know you
know even
in terms of christianity itself you know
that if you
are too attached to to your orthodoxy or
your catholicism
then you know though there's something
wrong with you because we all need to be
ecumenical and all be together and
and there's this kind of idea of this
universal thing
but that is i don't think that's a
traditional christian trait at all i
think it's
it's rather a kind of weird progressive
thing that came about
in the 19th and 20th century um and it
led to atheism and it leads to kind of
atheistic uh a kind of weird atheistic
universalism
so you know that's what i thought that's
how i see it and i think that it's
difficult the conversation is so
difficult today because it feels like
people only see the world in extremes
they
they feel like it's either
you know they feel like it's either that
we need to just accept everything and
not
and not have any attachment to
to let's say that our the hierarchies in
which we are
it's either you know it's either we just
have to be open and everything is the
same
or or or it's like we hold on to our
identities and we
create really strict borders and that's
been the 20th century and it seems like
in the 21st century you know we're more
on the
still on the side of the openness but it
feels like
it could clamp down at any time
so all right all right let's keep going
let me i just need to get i forgot to
take the chat out of the
pop out chat all right so i can at least
have a chat there
i struggle to look at the chat while i'm
talking but at least if i have it there
maybe once in a while i can catch
something in there
all right all right let's keep going
where were we
okay all right so david flores who i'm
sure is going to be very happy that i'm
doing it on sir gawain
and the green knight says in your recent
video on
prince yvonne he talked about the
relationship of the mount and the writer
you also discussed the firebird coming
down to eat the seeds
is the writer of principality on the
mount of body
when in communion adjoining of heaven
and earth yes indeed that's exactly what
a rider and a mount is it is really
a joining of heaven and earth and uh
you know it's like a positive joining of
heaven error so you can imagine you know
that image that you see sometimes there
are different versions of different
traditional societies of like an eagle
eating a snake or
you know a bird above and uh
and something below it's often an eagle
and a snake so it's like
there's this eagle eating the snake and
there's the snake attacking the eagle
let's say
so that is the that is like the hostile
relationship between heaven and earth
and the idea of the predatorial bird
which comes down and picks
things up is related to that predatorial
idea of the writing of heaven and earth
but
like you noticed the the idea of
a of a
of someone riding a horse and kind of
directing the horse and using the
horse's power but also caring
for his animal is is a very powerful
image of the joining of heaven and earth
a good example of that is in the psalms
you have this image of god
riding through heaven's you know on the
the back of a cherub
and so he's he's the cherub is his mount
which
is also represented as a chariot in
ezekiel so the idea of the divine
chariot
and then you know god coming down and
joining himself with the divine chariot
or riding the divine chariot across the
sky is
is exactly this unite this uniting of of
the two opposites
um
all right so numa ash asks
he starts with bear with me on this
question hopefully i formulate it in a
comprehensive way
so let's see i should tell i should read
these questions in advance to see if i
can
if i okay
so do you think that if someone like
columbus had discovered the americas
when an ancient biblical cosmology was
predominant
that there would have been less of a
shock at that discovery
it seems to me that world became bigger
to everyone
that even the edge of the world in a way
disappeared
it also looks like there would have been
just as much confusion though not in the
same ways
i thinking that the native peoples are
some of the lost tribes plus modern
types
there seems to have been a scramble to
figure out where the natives were
mentioned in the bibles
i'm not sure what kind of reaction would
have happened if this occurred before
the end of the first millennia
i hope that makes sense and so
i mean the question is
the big question is why do you think
that that
why do you think that columbus was
discovered in america i don't i don't i
don't think that
first of all i don't think columbus
discovered america uh
you know we know now that the vikings
were there before
maybe not that long before still like at
least three centuries before
maybe maybe more or and why do you think
that there weren't people who went there
before that
i don't know why people i don't know why
people don't
there are stories in the stories of the
saints for example saint brendan and
different
saints who travel west and discover
discover lands with people and stuff so
yeah it's just interesting it's it's
there's something about the renaissance
and the enlightenment and that period
where they act as if nothing existed
before them and everything they did was
just
you know was it and so to be honest i
don't i'm not i wouldn't be surprised at
all if
if there had been people who came to uh
america's in the roman times or
or even before that why not like it's
insane to think that that anyways
so that's one thing uh
and so and so you know i think that
one of the one of the problems
you know that happened in the time of of
columbus and after that
one of the biggest reasons why it caused
such a big stir
is also because
there was an expansionist desire of
course in the way that they were doing
things
and the exploration was framed in
economic terms
very very strongly in economic terms and
then ultimately in political terms
so i think that that's what made the
biggest difference the idea that some
explorers would have gone there to north
america
and just talked to the people or you
know stayed there or died there
you know come back with a few things you
know is more
related to the idea of let's say marco
polo of
of the voyager who goes out but columbus
and the people who followed him they it
was all done in a
in a kind of weird pseudo-scientific
desire to map everything but also
in economic and political terms and
that's why it had such such a big
that's why it made such a big difference
because it ended up changing
the world they invaded all those lands
and so they it changed everything
um
so phil asks hi jonathan i'm seeing the
color purple used frequently in social
media ads sometimes related to public
health
coven 19 messaging but also in other
messages that ostensibly convey
safety and security bank government does
purple convey a special meaning in line
with this
uh so it depends on which purple like
there is a
there is a purple i i don't i would have
to see the images you you talk about
there are some purples that are related
to kind of royalty
and and uh and we still have a memory of
the purple as being an image of
of uh empire and of of class and
something that is
you know very important so that in that
sense it could be related to safety and
security and all that
there are other forms of purple you know
kind of lilac purple and those types of
purple that are used more
mostly as a kind of fusion of blue and
red
and tend to be used in a way in places
where they want to
confuse the confuse the colors
uh i mean confusing since the to
manifest hybridization and so so
purple is often used in those in those
places
um all right so marge sniffing asks
all right you guys have to write shorter
questions sorry mark all right so
i've heard you use the words inevitable
a few times and i'm trying to understand
how
inevitable experience is or perhaps how
simply to talk about
inevitability i thought a fair bit about
free will versus determinism but i feel
that conversations framed that
way sort of reduce the universe and its
agents to causal machines
they also pit two simplistic extremes
against each other
i found that with most extremes
opposites
uh they need to be integrated into
something that actually reflects reality
patterns seem inherently
inherently inevitable how can we how do
we decide what to do when we live
in and are a pattern my instincts now is
to use language like aim
at being the right place
which might be the center as opposed to
trying to predetermine specific actions
am i barking up a dead tree and so in
terms of
inevitability
and freedom and and and free will
versus determinism i i think i mentioned
this before
we have to we have to get away from the
idea of free choice
as this idea of let's say ultimate free
choice
the real free choice as this idea of you
know you've got
sardines or this other kind of fish and
you choose between the two or you you
know you choose between
this color or that color that is not
true choice or it's not
primordial choice uh
the only let's say like in saint max and
the confessor
you have this idea that the only free
will
you have is to choose god your only your
will is only free
if you choose god if you choose
if you choose sin or if you choose your
passions then
your will is not free then you you
you actually become determined by
the patterns of your passions whereas if
you
choose god then you are free in the
sense that
you you start to rise above the little
patterns right just like you go up a
mountain
and then you start to be above the
particular pattern
and so you free yourself from
the little patterns of of death and of
of these cycles of passions that we kind
of get into you know what i'm talking
about
right and so you that is true freedom
and so that is the way we need to
understand freedom and so
and so freedom doesn't mean that you are
that you're free from the patterns
freedom means that you move you move up
the mountain and you you move towards
the center you move towards the sacred
space
and in that that's where you are
free and and like i've said
you're never to if you're free from the
passions
you're a slave of god if you're if
you're as
if you're free if you try to free
yourself from god
and you choose the passion then you
become a slave of passions
and so we we're not
you know we we're always in a hierarchy
and it just depends on where you want to
place yourself
in that hierarchy that's inevitable
we're not completely free
in the sense that we're not god we can't
create the world
we are bound by the possible we are
bound by all these
these things we we can't do whatever we
want because
because we are bound um and and often
we're not doing whatever we want most
people who say
that they're doing whatever they want
are the most are the worst slaves of
their passions because
it's an illusion they're actually just
following their their passions
um all right so tan moose man asks
my choir director dismissed the concern
i had with scorn
i suggested that men wearing masks was a
head covering and that it was not fit
inside the church beneath a man's
dignity
you guys are looking for fights after
watching your talk on mask as veils i'm
more convinced that i wasn't just being
legalistic
but perhaps what do you think is this a
head covering not fit for christian men
in church
i've heard this is a sort of secular
sharia and it feels like a foreign
ritual observance which is not
catholic in my case or generally
christian but pagan maybe
as i ask you if this is a hill we're
dying on
in church would you could explain why
it's not fitting of a man's
dignity to veil where it is for women
um and then he says my whole family is
on board with the jonathan
jonathan pedro inspired symbolic
movement now thank you for all you do
so to be honest i i do not think
that i i do think that in something like
wearing a mask
which which is not a
can i say this at least for now
i would say that you need to submit to
your authorities and you need to
to follow what your spiritual
authorities
are telling you to do um and it doesn't
mean that
if you feel like the church is going in
an odd direction
and that following these rules are like
you said or kind of submitting the
spiritual to physical concerns
completely
then i i understand you and i think it's
good to be attentive to that
and to be thoughtful about it um and to
not
and to not to to still remain wise as a
serpent
and we need to watch where this is going
to be honest i don't think that
right now asking people to wear masks in
church
at least in terms of the parishioners i
don't
think that that it's enough to rebel
against your authorities
and uh and so you know if people
if people this for example if a church
says that from now on we're never going
to have communion anymore because it's
not hygienic
and we can't we can't do it you know uh
then i would say that's those types of
moments are the moments where you kind
of have to ask
to start looking around you know and
seeing
what's going on and maybe asking more
questions and being a little more
pushing things a little real a little
more um
so and i like uh
like with all the lockdowns here and
everything that's happened and how
complicated it is i have to be honest
with you guys i haven't been
i haven't been to church since colgate i
haven't i haven't gone back and
and and and to be honest like to be
honest it has something to do with what
you said
and maybe i'm wrong maybe it's not okay
for me to do that but
it's like i think i would struggle
i would struggle with with wearing the
mask in the church
uh and so until now i've kind of avoided
it which is probably
hear me giving you advice but probably
not the right advice
because i don't think on the i don't
think on that
in that this case that i am right i
think that i am
that i might be just avoiding the
question which it's gonna well right now
we're being logged down anyways now so
now it's gonna be all closed down
so all right guys
it's been crazy
okay so luca ascovic asks i have a
degree in fine arts but i sort of gave
up on art
even before i got my diploma after
several years of working on jobs and
doing
nothing art related i'm looking to come
back to art since i realized
that the only thing in which i have
practical knowledge
in and do enjoy it when i can focus so
my problem is i'm very easily distracted
to the point
i don't notice that i'm focusing on my
work and i can't even dedicate an hour
to a day on drawing
and i do have free time my mind wanders
all the time when i'm by myself and it's
followed by this cluster of emotions and
thoughts that i have
other things to do i'm not good enough
this is not the thing i should dedicate
my life to
do you have any advice on how to be more
focused on work
what do you do to be more focused um
you know to be honest luca i'm kind of
like you you know
if you notice that i you know my videos
are not organized in categories i
i don't kind of follow a thread or do a
systematic teaching of something
i tend to to kind of hop around and so i
have that kind of artistic disease of
being distracted and also not being
how can i say this of sometimes
struggling to find the energy to do
things
and uh and what i've done in my case
is i i've set up look it's different
from you because i work this is my
job so this is what i do full time what
i've done is i've set myself up in a way
that i have
a lot of things to do in terms of
working on my videos working on my
carving
you know working on the orthodox arts
journal working on the symbolic world
writing
uh you know uh also having discussions
with other people
uh inviting people on the participating
and other people there's all these
things that i
have that i can do and in those i also
have different
things to do and so what i tend to do
with my the way i do things is
is that i have so many things to do in
different spheres that when i
feel like i can't concentrate on one i
often
seems like i have energy to concentrate
on the other and so what i do is i try
to
shift my attention based on what i'm
able to focus on um
and then that ends up in my case it ends
up that i'm actually able to
be extremely productive because you know
i just kind of
i just kind of i just i just kind of
take this and do this for a while then
go to this and do this other thing for a
while and do something do these other
things
um and so that's the way i do it in your
case what i would say is
i would say to
find something okay how it depends on
you like one of the things that i would
do if i were you
is i would draw when i'm doing something
else and so
for example uh
it depends if you're able to it's like
for example like we sit around the table
my with my kids and we kind of chat and
we talk
and we all sit there and we draw and so
i draw while i'm sitting with my kids
and i'm talking with them
and doing something else sometimes
actually helps me to focus
another thing i do is i listen to
podcasts so while i'm carving i listen
to podcasts i listen to audiobooks
and then it prevents my why my mind from
wandering because i'm focusing
on the podcaster on the audiobook and
then i can
then i can carve when i'm doing that i
can carve like all day
if i'm listening to to to different
things because then
i don't tend to uh i don't tend to
wander and so that's something i can
suggest doing you could read the
scripture you can listen to scripture
readings you can listen to
to uh you know just like in monasteries
that's what they do
during lunch in order to prevent people
from minds from wandering and to kind of
also vain conversation they tend to read
uh the
texts from um from scripture or from uh
or from the church fathers
so masar ah sorry so edt asked why are
abstract concepts
like liberty justice and wisdom uh
personal personified as female
um i would have to think about that i
don't know
i don't know i don't know why the the
modern
these are all modern personifications
you know uh
these are all kind of enlightenment
personifications and so i don't really
know
why all the enlightenment goddesses are
all
women for some reason i never really
thought about that
to think about it all right so
masar asks in your recent talk about
angels and demons
i'm wondering if angels are capable of
possessing someone
as demons are can an angel be incarnated
in the flesh as the logos was
what is the meaning of socrates's demon
was it benevolent is not greek stoic
idea of the universal logos not based in
part on this
demon is this a prefiguration of christ
and so no angels
should you angel should not possess you
uh because
that notion of of you wouldn't call it
the same thing as possessing
right you wouldn't call it the same
thing as possessing because possessing
it means it has something to do with
obsession and so when you're possessed
by a demon there's also an obsession
which comes with it a
type of acting you know despite yourself
you know giving in to your passions it
can be as
as subtle as you know a passion like
pride or lust or whatever but it can
be as immediate as someone who
is you know trying to scratch their eyes
out or trying to pull their hair out or
acting in a manner which is actually
physically damaging to the person
and so that is what the idea of
possession looks like
now
this is this this so i i believe
that you can manifest
higher principalities that and this
is not done in a way that is a
possession
but rather it's the idea let's say
a good way to understand it would be to
imagine that if you
are a warrior for example let's say
you're a soldier
and you have a patron saint or you have
say michael is your patron i think that
it is possible
that you would manifest the
the strength of saint michael right that
you could
manifest some aspects of the of
a higher principality but it would not
appear to you
as a as a possession because it wouldn't
be something that
would that would kind of
take over and and uh and overwhelm your
your will but rather it would be a
lifting up
of yourself and you would feel in a way
maybe like you're even more
yourself as you are manifesting the
virtues of these saints or of the
of the of the angels and so maybe that's
a good way to understand
it now in terms of socrates's demon i
think that
really here you really do have to
imagine
socrates as demon maybe something more
like a something like
you know the angel and the demon that
you see on the shoulders and the
cartoons
i think that it has something to do with
that and that it has something to do
rather with the idea of
of the higher his higher self or
like you said something like the aspect
of himself which is connected to
something higher
and so he would have access to that
he could in certain guys as kind of like
someone who is praying or someone who's
meditating could have access to
some higher aspect of himself and that
then he would it would bring wisdom in
him like it would manifest wisdom
and so i think that that's i think that
that's
possible and i like you said i i don't
necessarily think that socrates is demon
is the same thing that we talk about
when we talk about demons because
i definitely don't see socrates as being
taken over or overpowered by
by some behavior or passion or something
so all right so we are done with
the symbolic world
i just also want to to remind you guys
that
there are a lot of amazing articles
getting published on the symbolic world
blog today
you know there's this wonderful uh this
wonderful uh
article which was published on a
georgian kind of
festival ritual and uh i forget the name
of the person
right who wrote it which is horrible um
let me find it quickly just because it
was really great
okay and so it's by daniel padronos
and it's called the symbolism of the
supra uh really great article
going through the ritual and then
showing how it is really is this
manifestation
this union of heaven and earth even
using some of the patterns that mature
uses in his book language of creation
and so it's really great there's uh
nicholas kotar
wrote a great article recently as well
called the constellation of fantasy and
uh
so i'm just i'm just really excited to
see all the stuff that's going on so i'm
really encouraging everybody
to get involved and to read write
comments get involved in the discussion
all right so here we go so going to
subscribe star
so dorothy kkk asks hi jonathan
when i read the bible when i read the
bible and get to a verse
or some other part that really speaks to
me i recognize it as an advice or a
warning
for my personal life is this some form
of mapping the pattern onto my life
or am i just seeing something that isn't
there can a pattern always be matched to
the personal life or just sometimes
no you're no the the bible
the traditional way like even the
traditional western medieval way of
understanding the bible is that it
it has interpretations at different
levels and it has a
metaphysical interpretation it has a
kind of theological interpretation
it has there's a more social
interpretation and then there's also a
personal
interpretation and so yes there is room
uh for the bible to manifest itself
at the personal level you know um
i would say that to be careful with that
a little bit
i would say that if you're in a church
that you should always
read your bible uh let's say within the
authority of the church
and you know the best would be to have
someone who can kind of guide you
to kind of guide you in that as well to
be to be sure to be careful not to fall
into
kind of prayer last a kind of idea that
spiritual pride you could say where you
feel like god is talking to you through
the bible and that
you know you need to do this or that god
is showing me to do this or that
god can show you to do things but there
is a danger
going down that road where people kind
of get carried away
um and uh can kind of end up blindly
following their own
dis illusions thinking they're following
god
so so it's better to have people that
you can ask advice from
hi jonathan what would you say to
someone who insists that god
could have created the world without
evil because god can do anything
i think you may have talked about talked
a little about this before but i would
appreciate
any more you could say on it um
okay i should laugh because it's like
it's you know it's the problem of evil
and the problem suffering is the biggest
problem in terms of theology
but i would say that god could not have
created a world
that was truly
that was truly fully one and many
that really had this relationship of the
one and the many
without the possibility of evil because
you can't have many without the
possibility of fragmentation
because if if god would just impose
himself his goodness
down into everything in a way that
doesn't leave room for things to have
autonomous existed existence or real
existence within god
then then what is it then it's it's not
it's not does it it's not actual
existence so for something to actually
exist
there has to be in it the possibility
of multiplicity and therefore the
possibility of fragmentation if it
doesn't stay united to that which
is its origin that's as good as it's
going to get for me but
you know it is it is a difficult
question in the the problem of evil and
the problem of
suffering so what is the importance of
saint john so nicolas
what is the importance of saint john the
baptist we have had other prophets
announcing the coming of christ
why is it important for christ to have a
prophet announcing him
has he is entering the stage so to say
and so in the sense in the
saint john the baptist really is very
important
because he's also not just a prophet
who's announcing christ
you know there aren't a lot of stories
about him in scripture but he's
presented at least by christ
as the last prophet as the ultimate
prophet as the culmination
of the prophetic tradition and so in a
way he
is a condensation of
the prophetic tradition and then
you can imagine like he's not an
incarnation
but he's a he's like a condensation of
the whole prophetic tradition
into one character and then that
character
is pointing to christ
and he's saying there he is right
um and so that is the that is the
importance of saint john the baptist
and also because there is this idea that
before
the messiah comes elijah comes to clear
the way
elijah comes to level the road you know
and so saint john the baptist has a
you could call it like a kind of
destructive character not in a bad sense
but in the sense of
you know he calls out the king he calls
out hypocrisy
he tells people to repent he's trying to
break down
the corrupt system so christ actually
christ doesn't have that as much right
christ is trying to save the lost sheep
but he's not he doesn't spend his time
uh
attacking especially not the political
authority christ does criticize the
spiritual authority
but he doesn't criticize the political
authority in the way that saint john
the baptist does um and so i would say
that
that's the importance of saint john
all right and so all right let's move on
to patreon patreon always has
the most questions and so how many
questions on patreon
like 25 questions or something all right
all right everybody's happy in the chat
happy to see brad there who else is
there
that i know shane kawelty all right
it's always hard to know derpa robbins
yes good to see neil there all right
all right enough that
see this is how this is how much i can
do with the chat is just look there and
see if there's people i know in there
all right so okay so here we go so paul
jamal
i don't know if you're pronouncing your
name right paul paul damascus says hi
jonathan
can you please elaborate on the fact
that christians do not go to heaven
does this misconception come from
misguided materialist reading of dante's
divine comedy
thank you for your work um
so yeah so there there is a way
in which so the best way to understand
it is that there is a way in which
christians
go to heaven in the sense that there is
this ascension
right this ascension towards
that which is above always this going up
the mountain you know ascending the
divine ladder
and so you can see in all that imagery
this idea of ascending has to do with
the notion of going to heaven but the
problem with
when i say christians don't go to heaven
it mostly has to do with this idea that
people think that
you die and you go to heaven you don't
die and go to heaven
you could say that you're trying you're
you're reaching
towards heaven your whole life you're
reaching towards heaven your whole
existence you're ascending
the hierarchy the spiritual hierarchy of
virtues your whole
existence um and so the idea of dying
and going to heaven
that there's that's not the that's not
the
that's a that's not how it works right
it doesn't work not because you die that
you go to heaven
going to heaven is the transformation of
the person this
ascension of the person up the the
the levels of the spiritual hierarchy
that's what going to heaven is
um and so
in terms of eschatology in terms of what
happens after you die
there's rather the idea of of the
resurrection that's the final result
of of the totality
so there's this idea that that nothing
is lost right nothing is lost in the
world
consciousness the pattern of of
consciousness is something which
exists beyond your current body
and that there is a matter in which
that pattern is is going to exist in
the totality of things and that includes
a
form of bodily existence now i don't
know what that is i
i don't want to speculate on what that
means but
it's rather understanding that that
patterns for patterns to really exist
they need to have
a body there there are
no pure patterns you know the pure
patterns
is the only pure pattern is the divine
logos and the divine logos
manifested himself in the flesh and
his the and his body is the communion of
the saints
so you could understand that that
creation
you know ultimately all of creation
becomes
something like the the the body of the
divine logos something like that
um and so things exist in
in in bodies not necessarily physical
bodies all the time
but it could be subtle bodies as well
that's a whole other question i keep
promising you that i'm going to talk
about subtle bodies
but i need to find the right ways to
talk about it so it doesn't sound like
i'm just spouting gibberish
all right so kyle ready's asked
i am an artist who's being pulled into
the beauty and wonder of iconography
any suggestions to someone that is new
to painting icons how to keep it
traditional
but alive in the present any current
past iconographers to study
thank you god bless and so i think
the best way to
the best way to connect to iconography
is to find teachers
it is you know it is possible to learn
iconography on your own
but it's probably best not to it's also
probably best if you're going to study
iconography
to do it within the confines of the
church because
this is it's a traditional art that is
part of a bigger
set of relationships you know i've
talked about this before where icons
don't exist
in a vacuum icons are related to the
church architecture are related to
the processions are related to the
liturgy they're not they're not isolated
in terms of their in terms of their
existence so that's probably best
um but you know it there it is possible
also to if you want to if you want to
kind of start out
and and and try to see what you can
learn on your own there are some books
that you can look at aiden hart's book
uh what is it called the techniques of
icon and
wall painting i think it's called sorry
if i get it wrong uh but
that even in heart's technical book is
really amazing it has everything in it
you need to know
in terms of of studying iconography the
the practice
there are also people online who are
giving some
drawing classes um
and so yeah so you can you can look at
that on on i forget her name
i'm horrible with names if she knows
that i forgot her name she's going to be
very angry with me
uh there is an iconographer on patreon
who's doing kind of weekly classes on
drawing and so she films herself drawing
and that can be helpful to learn to draw
at least learn to draw from the inside
okay so arie fisher asks hi jonathan
so you've just about gone and fully
evangelized me and i'm currently
wrestling with the decision between
catholicism and orthodoxy
in many ways i myself do not actually
care about it so much but a lot of the
debate between
the two seems to revolve around the
papacy i'd like to hear your thoughts on
the legitimacy of the papacy it seems to
line up with a pattern of hierarchy
and seeing as you're a confessed
monarchist i wouldn't necessarily
guess that you've had a problem with
concentrating all the authority in one
person but maybe it's different with the
church
in most areas i'm more attracted to
orthodoxy but i must admit it seems
pretty effective
the catholics have a living authority
they can turn to for the final decision
if need be and
it also seems to give them more unity
thanks for everything you do
and so i i this is
not everybody will have the same opinion
on the pope i tend to think
that at the outset the notion that
rome had some kind of supremacy
let's say a kind of uh supremacy of a
toritas
in the way that the romans understood it
and so
the romans understood
there was this idea that authority is
the kind of
informal influence you get from being
the the superior like the older brother
or something like that right the older
brother has
more authority to us and so because he's
the older brother
he he we look to him we look to the
elder we look to the
to the to the person who is there who's
like i said the eldest
to kind of help us out to maybe
sometimes arbitrate some things or
whatever
and that's the way the orthodox
perceived the the
function of the pope so the the roman
pope was kind of like an older brother a
someone that
could arbiter let's say disagreement
someone people look to
um but he didn't have potestas he didn't
have
legal capacity to
manage all the local churches and i
think that that's mostly in terms of
papacy
where the the orthodox church
uh disagrees completely that the the
pope
can't decide the bishop of a local place
you know that
all the churches have their own
independence to a certain extent
each bishop is the head of a local
church
and you know and some bishops are more
let's say important in terms of their
influence but
they don't have legal authority like
even for orthodox you know
the the the patriarch of constantinople
is
has if the patriarch of constantinople
tries to decide
who my priest is at my parish no one's
going to listen to him
like he doesn't have that capacity to
reach down and
and influence all the way down so it's
so i think that that's
one of the biggest problems people have
in terms of uh
in terms of the papacy and also you know
there's some things like
obviously the idea that the pope is uh
is infallible in certain situations i
think that is
that can be problematic if if it's
abused
yeah the orthodox church tend to seek
collegiality as
the the source of of truth in the church
that is that there's a communion and
collegiality
and that manifests the the reality of
something
all right so christian sakra asks i've
watched the gods angel demons podcast
and enjoyed hearing about the token
lewis attempt
to work higher order beings into their
writing have you ever read or heard of
c.s lewis's
uh space trilogy i'm sure you've got
plenty of reading recommendations but i
think they're the
his best attempt at describing
principalities and they s
they seem to go mostly unnoticed you
know i really
i tried to read those i read but it was
a very long time ago
i read the first book and i remember
kind of liking it and then i started
reading the second book
and i i just kind of fell off and so
maybe
it's time for me to look at you know i
don't read enough cs lewis so
you know i i keep telling myself okay
i'm one day i'm gonna i'm gonna do an
audio book binge of c.s lewis's book uh
but it hasn't happened yet so
but yeah sure i mean i'd be happy to to
read it at some point
all right so aj doctorio asks
my question is on a topic you've already
discussed the literal versus symbolic
meaning
i have to admit i'm still having a hard
time while reading the old testament
because i think
i'll think did this actually happen
for example did the israelites actually
escape egypt or no
that said i've tried to summarize your
view as best as possible as i understand
it
can you let me know if i'm close deepest
reality consists of patterns and the
best way for us to grasp these is
through stories and symbols therefore
even if something in the old testament
didn't actually happen in the most
literal way
the specific way that event has been
remembered and handed down may still
convey truth
about this deepest reality hey
uh i think it's just interesting i think
that we really
i think that i just don't think like you
i just don't think that way i don't i
don't have
the same categories and and i i
understand that this can be frustrating
for people uh
we don't have the past you don't have it
it's not there it's it's the only place
where the past is
is in the present that the past doesn't
doesn't exist anymore it exists as
memory and so
i don't understand like i don't
understand
the the pain you have and asking
yourself
whether or not the israelites escaped
egypt thousands of years ago like i just
don't understand that pain that you have
for me that is a totally non-existent
pain
and so something like that they think
something
like did the israelites actually escape
egypt or no
is almost
impossible to prove or disprove using
historical methods it's so long ago it
and so i don't
it's like i just don't have the same
categories it's like so my answer to
that is yes it did happen
and let's just move on uh
does it describe the events the way that
modern historians would describe the
events the answer is no it doesn't
but the way that modern historians
describe events
is also maybe not the standard by which
we should describe events
and so i think that maybe the problem
you have is rather that
you're you're holding on to a way of
describing that
is maybe even non-existent like
anyways i i i don't i struggle i i made
i'm sorry i know i'm i'm disappointing a
bunch of people when i kind of answer
this way but this is really this is
really how i
i view i view the world i really don't
and and you know what like
ask me also like ask me did did the
trojans
uh did the the greeks invade troy and my
answer is going to be yes
too it's going to be yes the the greeks
invaded
troy uh and
and and that doesn't i don't have any
qualms about saying that because
that's the that's the story that our
ancestors told
and that story is
is more true than any statuette that
they find in the desert because that
statuette is going to be unproven or
reproven or
dis or something else is going to pop up
you know
all scientific truths all historical and
scientific truths
have a a a kind of expiration date on
them
you know because they get they get
upended by some other like thing that
they find in the desert or
or some reinterpretation of how things
were you know
it's like when did rome fall and then
people are gonna start to
to argue so i don't know i just don't i
just don't
i just don't uh sorry man i hope i know
i'm disappointing you
but that's just how it is for me
so sandra cuter asked hopefully some
stability has returned to your home now
how did your children manage their new
school environment thanks for your love
uh man now they're locking us down again
and
our house is not finished and they're
they're they're locking down
uh all businesses are gonna be locked
down to 25
capacity and so i don't see we're going
to be there before christmas now because
there are already massive delays for
everything we were using
to fix up the house in terms of redoing
the floor in terms of
it's just been crazy trying to find
people to do stuff and so now that we've
heard today that we're being locked down
again
like i don't know when we're gonna go
back but how are my children managing
the new school environment i would say
that
pretty well in fact they're doing quite
well um
and uh yeah it's that's been pretty
positive
of course it depends like my son is
pretty keen on
recognizing propaganda so he sometimes
comes home and says
do you know what they said at school
today can you believe what they said and
i'm like yeah i told you it's gonna be
like that you just have to stay keep
your eyes open and be
attentive um you know we'll see with my
younger one she's
she's younger so i don't know how that's
gonna go we'll see they might close the
schools anyway so it would just all be
home school again
all right so vic serda asked hey
jonathan hope all is going well
my question is what is the meaning of
the staff of moses turning into a
serpent and eating the opposite
opposing serpents of pharaoh's magicians
i heard you say that the staff of moses
is related to
the cross of christ but how does it come
into play here
and so if you understand it
so using the cross of christ is probably
the best way the best way to understand
this staff of moses doing what it's
doing
you know and the staff of moses
okay so the staff of moses turning into
a servant
and eating the pharaoh's magician's
serpents
is the same story as as
moses putting a serpent up on the staff
and then people who look to that serpent
are healed from the serpents below that
are biting them okay
so those two stories are completely
analogous to each other to each other
they're
almost the same story okay and so
so the way to understand it is it
related to this idea
of turning death against death uh is
and so you have a situation where there
is this the staff of moses there are
these serpents
attacking say you have moses and you
have the serpents attacking
and the staff becomes a serpent
and kills the other serpents and then
becomes a staff again
and so you can imagine christ is
the king is the divine logos is the
highest thing ever
he comes down he becomes death he
becomes sin
in order to defeat sin in order to
defeat death
and so uh that is the
this idea that i always talk about of
this this flip
this turning of death against against
death
the transformation of death into glory
all these things are related to
this notion and so you can understand it
as a
you can understand it as the the the
the serpents you know or the the serpent
as a circle
you know or the periphery as a circle
and so you
you you have to understand the circle
also as having two
extremes one which is lower and one
which is higher
in bible it's represented as the
dividing of the water so there's the
waters above and the waters below
and there's a way and this is the
mysterious
idea of the incarnation it's the mystery
of the fall it's the mystery of
redemption it's the mystery of
resurrection
there's a way in which the lower
waters can be flipped and transformed
into the higher water so the way in
which death
can be flipped and transformed into
into glory and so
yeah that's as good as it's gonna get
um all right so
jay garcia asked hello jonathan my
question is what is a symbolic view of
humor
and how does it relate to play theory
or the other theories uh i've i did a
video on that you might want to check it
out
i think i called it uh
i forget what it's called something
about the purpose of laughter
um so you can try to find that and
you'll get a sense of what i talk about
i think that
the laughter has to do with
everything that's on the outside
everything that's on the periphery it's
a
okay laughter is an involuntary reaction
to an event right it's a loss of control
and so in the sense so in one way
laughter can be
you know there are some traditions would
say something like christ never laughed
okay
because christ never lost control christ
never gave in to the world
um at least not involuntarily right
and so that is really the symbolism of
laughter but laughter also has the
capacity
to question right to question authority
and to question the system to question
the the and so when a a system is broken
then you can see
laughter as a way to break it down and
so a story
an example i use all the time is of
course elijah
when the the prophets of baal have set
up a kind of upside down world in
israel then then elijah comes and he
mocks them and he makes fun of them and
he laughs
because you know he is trying to break
down the corrupt system
and so that is the that is the capacity
or the possibility
of laughter and so i think you know one
of the reasons why i talk about watch
the fools watch the clowns
is because one of the things that's been
happening
is that laughter at least in the last
few years has been used by several
people
to kind of restore a a vision of
order or a vision of a of a normal world
all right so lucas fernbach asked could
you talk about gideon
and the symbolic meaning of his story my
grandfather
picked gladius dominique gideon
the tuba torch and sword
for our family crest my profile pic
secondly could you give your opinion
about the laws and rules
in in
five mo's say
what i don't know what that is five mos
a 12 26
in the context of today's liberal
society um
i'm not sure what that is i'm sorry
uh i can talk about i can talk about uh
the uh the story of gideon a little bit
um
the story of gideon it has to do with
tricks
with tricking it has to do with the with
with uh with
with the idea of these upside down
things that
that kind of that kind of manifest and
are able to take over
so a lot of things that are happening in
the moment where israel is taking back
the land
have to do with this type of behavior
this kind of
tricking turning around the city you
know in the
um
sorry in the in the the my brain is is
completely
dead now uh in the story of joshua where
they turn around the city and they they
break down the
the city uh so it has to do with with
something like that where
gideon kind of tricks the different
people
uh by having more you know he has these
these flames and so they think that
they're more than they are
but i would have to look at it again
because to be honest
it's like i don't i i'm trying to call
back the full story
but i'm missing because i even like i
know that the story with the water where
they drink the water
it's like i even forget which ones are
the ones that
are in his army are they the ones who
bring the water to his mouth or go down
in the water
so i'd have to look at it again there's
and then there's the whole idea of the
fleece and the dry and wet
i'd have to think about it again for
sure it's a it my memory of it
was that it had very a lot of symbolic a
lot of symbolic stuff but i would have
to re-go over it again sorry
also because right now all right
okay so charlie longoria asks
so do you have any advice for someone
who has become a catechumen in the
orthodox church i've been attending the
church since june 2020
and have now decided to become a
catechumen unfortunately after that
first service i attended
our priest was struck ill not covered
related so we've only been having typica
services for the past few months
a priest from san antonio is san antonio
is able to come once a month to give
communion
our priest is slowly recovering however
this is not an ideal solution no man i
feel for you i'm sorry
um yeah i don't i don't know i would say
it is i would say that maybe you can
talk to your priest
about uh resources that you can start
with on your own
you know just ask him if there are some
books you could read
or if there are people even i know it's
not ideal but if there are people
online let's say some priests online
that are willing to kind of help
while he is kind of getting better and
having more energy to help you through
this
um but at least for now i would say
that's the best you can do but i would
say maybe ask your priest who's
recovering
what he suggests you know what he
suggests you should do in terms of
of uh of being a catechumen
in the great so norm grenadas in the
great adventure bible the
nation of israel is described in the
section of the conquest and judges
joshua judges and one samuel as falling
into a continuous cycle of sin servitude
supplication salvation
and silence in light of your recent
emergence talk with john d
and paul v you're you discussed the idea
of story and the breakdown of meaning
elsewhere you discuss the idea of loss
of memory as an inevitable consequence
of moving further and further away from
the center
in what ways might this breakdown of
meaning be a symptom
of forgetting silence
in what ways might this breakdown of
meaning be a symptom of forgetting
i don't know why you put silence there
because i don't see silence as
forgetting
um and so the book of judges
so the book of judges is showing you how
when you don't
have a stable authority then you
you have extremes you have these
extremes and this cycle
and so yes you're right what it is is it
is this
cycle right of this this movement
of cycles and you can see that in the in
the book of judges
it's continually saying something like
you know
uh israel did not have a king right
israel did not have the king in the land
and so it's actually it's something like
the story of the
uh of the greek tragedies you know where
you you you have the my my brain is
completely gone tonight i'm sorry guys
uh what's the name of that cycle the
greek tragedy cycle there's a greek
tragedy cycle where
you have this this breakdown of meaning
where all the taboos are broken and
and uh you know things starts to cycle
and then there starts to be like the sun
killing the father and the children
killing the parents
and there's this kind of cycle of chaos
and madness
um and then finally it's solved by
athena
who establishes law in athens
and so this the establishing of law and
the stable
like hierarchy is what stops the cycle
of vengeance and cycles of
fall and everything and so that is what
is represented in the story of the bible
as well is that
the the although the problem
although kingship has its problems in
scripture and uh
and even the prophets talk about what
the problems are going to be
nonetheless it ends up being a
stabilizing
force it they build the temple which is
a stabilizing force in terms of the
religious practice
they also create laws which will
stabilize the identity of the
of these tribes that are fighting
amongst each other and ripping each
other apart
and so i think that that's the best way
to understand it and so if you think of
my brother's book you can understand it
as
the book of judges is being a slave to
the cyclical pattern
right to be a slave to this this cycle
of time
whereas establishing space in the center
establishing
of the temple and establishing jerusalem
as the capital
the king is what is going to stop this
kind of endless cycle of turning
that happens in the book of judges
all right so jan peter yager asked do
you have advice for christian artists
who make paraliturgical art as ivan
woody puts it
in a secular domain who want to escape
the egocentric praise focused and
prideful culture surrounding it how can
i become less
and christ more in that specific context
with the criteria
this domain of art sets
i would say i would say that
to establish purpose for what you're
doing was definitely definitely be
helpful
you know and i don't know what your art
is but
it can be something the purpose doesn't
necessarily have to be
super high let's say but it can still be
a purpose
so for example if you say if you know if
you make visual art you could say that
your the purpose of the object is
to be beautiful and to decorate
a building and that might sound like a
very low purpose but it's actually a
higher purpose than a lot of
contemporary art has right now which is
to kind of be a
object of speculation and also an object
of
of thought you know it it's just
something that you think about and
write theory about and so you can
imagine that you have a purpose which is
to
so for example if you write music it
could be something like
you want to write music which will you
know you could write quiet you could
find a i don't know if i struggle a
little bit with
the concert music i don't it's okay
but ultimately it's folk music
and uh you know music that leads to
that can be something that's used in
weddings or
used for different occasions like
dedicated music you could say
it's probably something which would be
better and so in the past even what we
now call
concert music wasn't really concert
music it was
you know music written for the
coronation of a king or music written
for uh you know for for dancing or music
written with a purpose and so i would
say to rediscover purpose
is something that will help you
and also i do think that that uh i do
think that
if you imbibe the christian story and
the christian pattern
then that also will flow out into
secular art as well and so if you look
at medieval secular art it still had a
flavor and it still had
something aspiring towards the sacred in
it
um so leo asked do you have any thoughts
on systema the russian martial art
that allegedly was developed by orthodox
monks many centuries ago it has an
important school in toronto maybe
there's such a thing as christian
martial arts after all
i have to admit i have been really kind
of curious about this
this thing you know i i don't there are
no
if there aren't there's no one teaching
it around here and so
i've been just curious about like you
said i've been curious about its origin
because
i know that they use the jesus prayer
and they also use
uh like a kind of uh breathing
within the system um but i don't know
enough about it to know whether it's
legit or whether it's just something
some guy made up
um you know i've seen some pretty
impressive things
it's always hard to know when you're
watching videos whether or not it's
authentic but i've seen some pretty
impressive things of people
really giving powerful these kind of
powerful kung fu
looking punches where they hit someone
and the guy goes kind of flying back
and so it seems like it has something
like it's not completely
bunk at least that it has some kind of
so i would say you know i would say
look into it you know be curious about
it and
also be careful if it's some if it's
some kind of weird
kind of new agey stuff but uh i would
say i mean i don't know the story
yeah but i have to admit that i have
been kind of fascinated by it
so christopher asks seeing the
connection
being made between my wife and and
daughter during breastfeeding is
beautiful
i always think of the phrase the priest
uses during liturgy take eat this is my
body
man is there a connection between the
two or am i making connections where
there are none
uh okay
i would say it's not the same it's not
the same
in in a certain manner it's it's
opposite uh
and so in scripture there is the bread
of heaven
you know the mana which comes down from
heaven uh and then there's also
let's say the the food of the earth and
so the
the mother is the one who gives body
so the food that comes from heaven is
not one which is there to
to provide body it's there to provide
seed you would say it's there to come
down
as a as light or come down as seed or
or or concentrate right this
concentrated thing
um whereas the the food which comes from
below or comes from the mother is
the sustaining food it's the the food
that gives body
and so it has to do with the home it has
to do with the house with the womb all
this image of
the the the womb as body right
as your first home your first house
uh and so that's what it has to do with
so i would say
um it it's in a way they're they're
complimentary you would say and so
there's the food
which comes from heaven and then there's
the food which comes from the earth
and you need both all right so chase and
lindsay's
uh asked hey jonathan i'm curious what
is going on
with seoul saul's search for his
father's three donkeys
i feel like there is a lot more going on
there than a random donkey chase across
an unusually large span of land i have a
feeling the cities that
saul passes through probably all meant
something to the ancient hebrews that
might be lost a modern person
i also feel like there is some
significance with the anti-climatic
revelation of samuel that the donkeys
were already found do you have any
insight on this introduction of saul
i i honestly have never thought about it
and so
it is something that i would have to
think about
uh and i don't want to speak out of
place
and so for sure donkeys i mean i can say
something about donkeys for sure
donkeys in scripture always
represent a kind of wild body you know
um and so
you know there's probably a connection
between this
saul searching for his three donkeys his
father's donkeys
not finding them all of that there's
probably a relationship between that
and christ entering into jerusalem on a
donkey
mastering uh mastering the donkey
uh and so there's probably a
relationship with that but i'd have to
think about it more
all right so kevin patterson asked hi
jonathan we've just passed the 19th
anniversary of september 11th attacks as
an australian who was too young
at the time to comprehend it i want to
understand the symbolism of this event
as it involves outsiders taking
possession of tech name machines of the
sky
large towers of business and trade
religious conflict conspiracy theory
and people choosing to jump off what can
we unpack here my goodness
you've said a lot of stuff you know
apologies if it's a sensitive topic
uh the only thing i can say
about september 11th in terms of
understanding symbolism
is that
the terrorists attacked
uh the highest thing of american
civilization
they attacked the god of american
civilization
you know they attacked the idol they
broke down the idol and so
by attacking the the world trade center
they attacked the highest thing american
civilization not just america but
western civilization
has pretty much given themselves to
economy and economy has become
the the god of our civilization we
we think of everything in terms of
economy we we make all our decisions in
terms of economy
and uh and so and so i think that that's
maybe the best thing to understand there
and that's why it was a they did it in a
symbolic act
of attacking the most important thing um
so yeah
so do mcmahon asks hi jonathan in the
story of the woman caught in adultery
jesus is asked by the scribes and
pharisees what her
fate should be and his response is to
initially write in the sand
emphasized by by being mentioned twice i
believe we are not told what he writes
and he appears to ignore the question at
first and goes right to writing
what is the symbolism of this gesture
writing on the ground happens at other
times in the bible as well
man i'll be happy i'll be honest with
you i've thought about that for a very
long time
i've i've kind of tried to ponder that
you know there are some people
there are some traditions about what is
written in the sand some people say that
christ was writing the sins of the
people in front of them
uh it seems like if what he was writing
in the sand was important it would have
been said i think that
the idea of christ writing in the sand
seems like it has to do with with giving
meaning to the sand it seems like it has
to do with creation
it has to do with blowing breath into
the sand or the dust that became
adam that's what i think it has to do so
i think that it
it's christ is manifesting who he is
by riding on the sand so so
being the putting meaning in the earth
right
and so and so i think that that's what
it is i think that it's
it's christ manifesting that
now why it happens there during the
story about the adulterous wife
is something that i'm not so sure it
could be something to do with him
being being the one who
i'm not sure like the one who's able to
free her who's able to kind of rise her
up from her accusers
because he's the one who gives meaning
and and
let's say is able to
to bring meaning into something that has
fallen so it could be something like
that but i'm stretching here but for
sure i knew
pretty sure that him riding in the sand
has to do with him
connecting meaning heaven and earth
together um
so take that for what it for what it is
uh so hey jonathan i was wondering why
no hume stones for an altar
why are tools and exodus said to defile
the altar is it something to do with
tool supplement being a product of the
fall
and thus sinful i find it interesting
that it comes just before
the plans for many wrought items of
worship kind of related how do you
sharpen your woodcarving tools
okay
yes i do believe that it has to do with
that i do believe that uh
the idea of having unhewn stone for the
altar
has to do with something which is
untouched something which is
pure something which is not worked it
has to do with virginity
and so it's related to the notion of the
mother of god
uh it has to do with this idea of
something which is not modified
something which is untouched and so it
is related to
the problem of the need to work the
earth
after the fall right when adam and eve
fall god says
you must work the earth and and hewing
stone like
cutting stone is really is related to
this work and so in that sense then the
altar becomes
the a place before the fall but also
related to the sabbath and to the idea
of
untouched you know the untouched part
the part that isn't that isn't uh that
isn't transformed
and so i think that that's what it has
to do with um
so like you said you say you find it
interesting that it comes just before
the plans
for many wrought items of worship so you
can imagine that the middle
so you so like that's the first thing
that said is they talk about the all
this altar
as being this untouched thing or this
kind of virginal thing
and then after that there can be all
these other things that are worked
but it's mostly mostly has to do with
that anyway that's how i understand it
uh so the wakeful asks jonathan
as a monarchist do you acknowledge queen
elizabeth ii as your true and rightful
ruler and respect her title of defender
of the face
thanks daniel ah man i really struggle
with that i struggle with that because
i'm french uh when i'm joking i say
i say yes i when i'm joking with people
around here i always say
i always kind of say what are you
talking about like i have we have a
queen there's a you look at the 20
look at her money she's everywhere she
obviously we have a queen
um but i think in practice i would say
probably to a certain extent yes but in
in practice it doesn't need much
although the the
the structures are still there like the
governor general is still the head of
the government in theory in canada and
so
it's like it's like there's this latent
structure which is still there in
in the canadian government that still
has a latent
uh royalty which could at some point
maybe be reactivated
so um i mean is she a defender of the
faith though i mean i don't know about
that i do have a problem with the
with with the notion that the
that the kings and queens of england are
you know considered like the head of the
church you know that is something that i
always found to be problematic i don't
know if it's still true but i know that
it was for a while
um all right so nina morris asks my teen
is hooked on symbolism from hearing me
listen to you
that's hilarious so now we watch movies
looking for it she asked me what is the
symbolism of toy story
in her analysis she suggests a push to
see each other as playthings and more
robotic
perfect than human cowboy versus alien
or
astronomy person from far away seems to
be
an old story uh
i i mean i never thought about the story
about toy story so i mean
in terms of the symbolism of the story
there is this this idea that you can
imagine it as
used to have a a microcosm
right a microcosm where
this the toys are there to serve
the boy to serve the child and so the
toys are
it's almost like the child is god and
they are a commun they are the church or
they are the
the communion of toys that need to get
along in order
to serve and to be you know uh
companions to this boy and so i think
that that's mostly what the symbolism
is about at least the first movies i
don't know about the other ones
i don't i forget even what the last one
was the last ones were about but like
the two first ones that i remember
they they seem to always be about you
know staying connected to the boy
staying connected to the child and
and uh you know also
being jealous that the child loves one
toy more than the other and
has favor has the god's favor and so
it's like uh the first tour story can
always be like a cane and able situation
where
you know uh woody has lost favor
uh with from god you know and uh what's
the other name buzz
has the favor of the higher aspect of
the hierarchy
and so then there's a conflict between
the two one tries to kind of
to betray or to uh or to kind of
sabotage the other
in order to regain favor with the child
um and so
i think that it has more to do with that
um so yeah
all right all right guys let's see
we're almost done we're almost done
so walrus king fourteen says
both you and materia's book have talked
about the symbol
the symbology of force in the past
primarily within the context of
encircling a city
the city and its walls are ordered
stability while which are holding back
the constant growth of the chaotic force
that surrounds
to me this gives forest a sort of
frightening and bewildering presence
which makes sense for those who have
ever walked through a deep forest
especially at night however in many folk
stories and fantasy novels forests are
lived
in by various peoples or races elves and
lord of the rings
a very heavenly almost angelic race
often stick out to me at first
how does living inside a forest work
symbolically can you
roughly go over the symbolic symbolism
of the forest in general to make sure
i'm on the right track so
so the idea would be that the forest is
the place of
chaos and and this dark kind of
this dark frightening place but it's
also the place of
potential and so it's also the place of
adventure
it's the place where you could find
surprises where you can
discover treasures where you could
discover something surprising
um and so i would say that even in lord
of the rings my understanding is that
the
the the forest elves are
the least let's say divine of the
of the elves like the they're the lowest
elves they at least that's my memory of
it
and so in that sense there's a reason
why they would live in the forest
whereas the other elves
don't and so that's that is how i would
say that
it needs to be understood but you can
also go
to let's say the hermit also lives in
the forest and so
there's also hidden knowledge in the
forest just like there's hidden
knowledge and hidden
uh sparks in the waters right
this idea of the fish in the waters or
the idea of of peter who goes out and
finds a gold coin in the mouth
of the fish is related to the fact that
hidden in the darkness hidden in the
forest
are these gems and these treasures
and so that's also one of the reasons
why
you know people go out on adventures and
go kind of outside themselves and then
find a gem or find a pearl and so that
is the that's the symbolism of the
forest so keenan wang
asked what is the meaning of jesus's
miracles
in particular how are we to interpret
some of the ones that seem like magic
uh curious hearing leprosy multiplying
physical food
i heard you talk about magic in a
previous video and that the christian
story is not about magic
so curing leprosy multiplying physical
food etc so all of christ's
miracles are different they're different
they're not the same they have different
meanings they usually all have to do
with the incarnation
and so they all have to do with the
effect
of of of the incarnation one of them
for example is healing bodies and so
that the
you know the light from heaven comes
down and it
it is able to heal the body it's able to
give meaning to something which is
breaking down
we give cohesion to something which is
breaking down so that
those are the those are the the miracles
that are related to
to um to healing there's also
the miracles related to food
and that has to do with this idea of
fishing right and so it has to do with
the capacity of the logos to go
into chaos and to into unknown and to
gather
that which is useful and then make it
into something
which has cohesion and so there's a
there's a mass of people
and they they they don't have enough or
it looks like they don't have enough
and and they they at least publicly only
have so many fish and so many loaves
but by the time christ is done then
that has he has been able to gather all
this other food out of the
out of the crowd and bring it you know
kind of manifest it
out of the crowd and so that is another
miracle and so it just depends all these
miracles like jesus walking on water is
obviously the same
this idea of mastering chaos mastering
possibility
um so anyways there are too many and so
i can't go into all of them but
every single miracle that christ
that christ performs has to do with
manifesting who he is and
kind of embodying or or making
real what it means for the logos to
become flesh
um all right all right so so
in theory we are done with the question
so let me check
in the super chats
sorry i don't have things as ready as i
did as i had before
because i just got that news about the
lockdown and i was just like sitting
around being frustrated
all right okay here we go
no
okay so here we are
right and so here we go so the golden
thread for ten
dollars um should we have faith
that your fellow countrymen didn't even
know will not ruin dune
i hope so he's a good storyteller i mean
you know it's like
i had my little problems uh with blade
runner but it was really
still really well put together and well
told uh
and uh you know
i will have to see you know if anybody
can do it i think he can
you know i'm a little worried that
they're not gonna make a lot of money
because
it's not it's not like dune is as famous
as other stories so
be interesting to see for sure
for sure it'll be interesting to see how
they play the weird all the political
need to uh to put in political messages
in dune and so that'll be interesting to
see if they they feel like they're
forced to do that or if they
they try to play it more straight laced
so andrew johnson for five dollars
asks
do you plan on retelling any more brief
stories the way you did with the story
of
the silence of silence and merlin sure i
would love to do that i
it's like i it's funny i don't feel like
people are interested in that but
if i did i would have to find stories
that are lesser known
um you know maybe doing some of the
alexander story
uh and also find things that i feel are
relevant and that i'd like to see how
people interpreted that
i really like i enjoyed that because it
was fun to watch people do a pretty good
job at interpreting the story of silence
um especially in the context today so i
thought that was good so i'd have to
think about which ones though
so david furtado asked for five br brl i
don't know what brl is
um does today's marriage have the same
meaning as in the bible can we consider
today's getting married on paper as to
becoming one flesh
and so i would say yes uh
i would say that if you
involve if you get involved in the in
marriage in a in
in a way that is really uh how can i say
this
is really uh a promise to the other
person and then you do it
in in completely even if it's a secular
wedding it'll still have a an effect and
it will still
create that effect of of of the two
becoming one flesh
you know and so the christians always
recognized uh
secular marriage even you know as being
legitimate they didn't they didn't you
don't need to be
married in the church i mean i think in
the orthodox church actually
but in the catholic church they actually
kind of they tend to recognize natural
marriage they call it
um and so but i think that yes i think
that
that you people should get married
because it's a
it'll shake you to your core you know
making that kind of promise
is very important to becoming an adult
and if you don't do that then you should
take vows and become a monk because
making those kinds of promises are
very important in becoming grown up
so shaky raindrop for 9.99 says thank
you you're welcome
mason bradford for 10 aud which i don't
know what that is
what is the unforgivable sin
and is there anything like it in the old
testament
i never thought about the old testament
question and so
the unforgivable sin is the sin against
the holy spirit
that's the unforgivable sin and so
like i don't want to step on anybody's
toes but i think it's the best way to
understand it is that the unforgivable
sin
is the sin of not wanting to be forgiven
it's the sin
of not it's the sin of refusing
god and that's the unforgivable sin like
of refusing
the transformation that god can
can can make in you and it's there's a
direct correlation it's like
if you don't want to be transformed by
the holy spirit
then you won't be transformed or you
won't be transformed by the holy spirit
and that's the unforgivable sin so it's
like
if you don't want to go up the mountain
then you're not you're not going to go
up the mountain it's not going to happen
so that's how i see it um
so tomorrow so thomas anderson asks
tomorrow's michael mass what is
orthodox view on the name michael who is
like god any unique markings on his icon
to make him out from
other angels i mean for sure say michael
is one of the most important i uh
one of the most important angels um and
so but i don't know if there's any
unique
things about his icon to mark him out he
tends to be
represented as a warrior because he's
the one who kills the leviathan and he
has a kind of warrior
position in the army of god uh he tends
to be represented in red
especially in the traditions in which
he's opposed to san gabriel who's in
blue
and so that sometimes uh i think gabriel
will
will be dressed in kind of
ecclesiastical garb will
look like a priest or a bishop and
whereas saint michael will look more
like a warrior and so you also have this
relationship between
spiritual authority and temporal power
uh so maybe that's the most i can say
about that so andreas
stamach stamatakis sorry i grew
up for five usd says i grew up orthodox
and was resistant to learning about my
faith but now i feel
the lack what can i read to regain
that connection um
i mean andreas i would say
the best the best way to do it is to
connect to a community
and i say that in the time of cogan when
i just told you that i haven't been to
church since the beginning of cohen so
i am being a very a hypocrite in saying
that right now but i still think that
that's the best thing you can do
is to is to uh is to connect
to people uh and then if you want to
read
there are some really good books that
have been written in the modern age
uh the orthodox the orthodox way
by bishop callisto's where is a very
accessible
but still very profound book that can
kind of help you get a sense
of of orthodoxy you know and then
obviously there's some modern
theologians that have written about
orthodox theology
i really like vladimirlovsky myself
although he's a little harder to read
but i would say uh i would say that the
the orthodox
the orthodox way is a good kind of start
if you want to learn a little more about
your faith
um and so paul l for 99 wow paul that's
thank you for that amazing gift and
doesn't even ask a question
so let me check if more
more so here's the last one and uh so no
more super chat for this
so a man born blind for five dollars
says
on the cross did christ curse god and
die
in a way job never did my god my god why
has thou forsaken me
um that's a really
really interesting question man that is
an interesting question
i would say easy answer is no
i would say difficult answer is
i would say that the difficult answer is
that he didn't
curse god and die but that it's as if
he comes
he's manifesting the extreme right he's
manifesting the
extreme which is actually impossible
he's manifesting the impossible extreme
of this idea of being abandoned by god
and so
he's going to the very very edge he's
going to
to to the edge of existence itself right
the
the edge of existence itself which
doesn't exist which which is impossible
uh and so he really is that that phrase
of course is the most
is the craziest phrase in scripture it's
one of the one of those things that is
just going to break every category for
you break everything
um and so i don't think that he is
cursing god and dying but i think that
it is referring to that i think that it
is
it is solving the puzzle it is solving
that puzzle
that happens in that in in job
and it's going there but he's not
cursing god he's asking
why have you abandoned me and but he is
going to that edge where
he's he's at the end of meaning right at
the end of
of possibility so so yeah
that's how i see that but it's a crazy
sentence
it just it's like don't think about that
too much because
thinking about a phrase like that it'll
drive you crazy
um and so so guys thank you for
thank you for your your time and i feel
like i wasn't
as annoying as i could have been
considering i just found out that we're
back
in lockdown um so so hopefully
hopefully that's that's that's true
and so everybody thanks for your time
thanks as usual for your support for
letting me do this
um and so last month i actually
didn't make as many videos as i as i
usually do because i've been
uh trying to get my carving back in
order i've been basically have basically
had kind of
not abandoned but had my i've been
struggling to carve with my house and
covet and then the flood and all of this
has just been crazy so last month i
really
locked down if you follow me on social
media you saw i posted a whole lot more
art than i usually do
and so now from now on uh so now the
videos are going to fall back in line
i'm preparing
uh some videos more videos on this idea
of parasitic storytelling
which is going to be more edited taking
more examples and movies and kind of
new and video games and tv shows so i'm
preparing that kind of stuff
and uh and like i said i'm also going to
put out very soon a video on uh sergey
went and the green knight
and so a 2d mhb
ask matt's matthew's next book and i
hope matu writes another book
i hope my tear writes another book um
but i don't know if it's gonna happen
because he
is he's he's yeah he's on a farm he's
living on a farm right now and he's uh
building
he's building uh tents and living on a
farm he's really
he's really going going all out
so uh so yeah um
and uh but he has agreed if you guys
follow the whole god's dog situation
where i am working on a um the graphic
novel that met you and i wrote
and is being illustrated by cord uh
that you might have seen follow him on
instagram by the way uh
i don't know where i can i'll post it on
social media where it's instagram
instagram is uh and uh materia has
agreed
to write a text on samson for
a kind of extra that we're going to put
out with that book we're going to have
the comic book and we're probably going
to have like an
extra that's going to have some articles
that i've written and material has
agreed to write an article on samson and
so that
is going to be awesome because that's
going to be like worth another book i'm
sure about that
so i'm excited about that so all right
guys thanks
for thanks for your time everybody
and i will see you next month guys
bye-bye